Hello. I wanted to be the first to congratulate you.
Congratulations on making it through, uh, the year.
Maybe you fist bump for more comfortable with that guys.
We did it the worst year on record,
a literal dumpster fire in some kind of a tsunami situation.
It just kept coming. Even think about the fact that it was a leap here. I mean,
what a slap in the face we had to take another day of this horrible year.
It just would not stop in every possible sense. This year was too long, too bad,
too sad. And I want to forget about it forever. I say, collectively, look,
let's erase it from the subconscious. Let's tear it out of the calendars.
Even vision shouldn't be described as 2020. It's just, you have good vision.
Now, now guys,
the other thing I want to say is that when exiting a bad year like this,
you have to be extra positive. Look, we need to start off on the right foot.
It's important to start 20, 21 off, right?
Because otherwise it could be just as bad is this year. And that for me,
for many of you, I know it's not an option.
So Mark my words and embarrass me later,
2021 is here. And I look, I want to,
I want to start off with a bang look, big announcement right off the bat,
go in daily boys, seven days a week, or at least that's what we're trying.
And to start, start it off. Look, I've just heard.
If you want to increase your odds of new year's resolutions like this,
actually sticking there's something called loss aversion that helps improves
your odds of success. What does loss, aversion, torture?
Self-inflicted torture if you fail your goal. So this can mean anything.
You know, you have to donate to a charity. You hate, you have to, you know,
get tased, shoot yourself with a paintball gun.
But although all that pain that's temporary. I had to think I had to dig deep.
What kind of person would be forever? What would I really fear?
And I came up with it, ladies and gentlemen,
if I miss an upload in January of 2021,
I will be going bald. Yes, that's right.
I will be shaving all this off gone by the way.
Some people they have like good head shapes. Yes, yes,
yes. Me not so much. Watch it sits unfortunate.
My head is a weirdly large uncomfortably, large, actually,
when you see it on my frame, I mean, if you see it in person,
but especially if this mask is taken off,
I think the contrast would be too much. I actually ran a little AI filter.
See what it would look like.
So you guys could see my torture ahead of time and I'm sure many memes will be
made of it if I actually have to go through with this.
So I'm going to try hard not to, uh, this is, this is what it looks like.
Enjoy not, not going to happen though. Not going to happen. It's not an option.
So that's what I'm doing. Let me know in the comments below what you're doing.
Look start 20, 21 off aggressively. Go, go in, make a big goal.
Tell me if you're going to do some loss of version two. I think be interesting.
If as a community, we were all hurting ourselves.
If we didn't even go through with our, uh, you know, gym membership plans, book,
reading goals, whatever you have going on in your life,
but I wish you the best look.
I know I'm a little bit cynical sometimes with these gurus looking at these
scams,
but the truth is I'm an optimist at heart and I wish you the very best of
years, 20. I'm not even gonna say, look,
last year has gone long live 2021.
See you in the next one.